TO CENTER ICE, BUR, WATCH
HIM FREEZE, FOREHAND, BACKHAND,
OVER THE GLOVEWANT.
>> IT WENT IN!
THIS TIME IT WAS
POINT.
WHISTLES ON THE ICE, UP AGAINST
THE FIRST LINES, AND THEY GET
COLORADO.
BYRAM DROPPED IT OFFNDS BY
THE MIDDLE.
LANDESKOG BUYS TIME.
ALL ALONE AND JUST RIFLES THIS
NET
FRONT PRESENCE THAT
BIG BODY IN FRONT OF
THE NET.
A POWER KILL.
>>VSKY, A LITTLE
HELP.
KEPT IT THAT PASS OVER
COLORADO UP 3-1.
FORWARDS.
>> NO S NOT
SCORING A SEGMENT.
>> I FORGOT ABOUT F TH
GAME FOR THE
AVALANCHE.
>> 0-1 WITH A COUPLE
R
PLAY FOR, SO HE'S
BYRAM.
THEYTEAMS IN THE LEAGU,
THEY GET ON THEIR
HORSE.
BYRAM JOINS THE
PLAYERS AND THEN P BY
RI>> GUYS IN THE
STUDIO TALKING ABOUT
PRESSURE AND WHO
IT'S ON.
COLORADO HASN'T BEEN
ABLE TO GET OUT OF
KUEMPER.
D AROUND BY
IAN MITCHELL.
DARREN HELM, GOO
YOU CAN'T ALLOW HIM
TO TAKE THAT SHOT.
Y
RANTANEN.
COME OUT.
LANDESKOG SHOT.
NEVER MADE IT THROUGH.
DE HAAN AND RANTANEN B B
CHECK.
>> PRETTY GOOD START
FOR THE AVALANCHE
BYRAM BACK OFF THE
BENCH.
KANE WITH A SHOT
JUST AS McCABE JUST
D. KEEK BEHIND
FOY WALKS IN
AND SCORES
BLOCKER ON THE STICK
SIDE OF DARCY
KUEMPER, GOALTENDER.